hello it's yo boi
AHHAA
*EAR RAPE* *Ow*
P-TO-DA-PIE!
with ma sidekick!!
*EXPLOSION*
So...eh..
You know I take a lot of shit..
OKAY
I deal with a lotta shit
everyday, okay..
YES
I read the comments, okay.
I like 1984...
...version PewDiePie better than today.
I preffered PewDiePie before... when he didn't have a toad
I prefer Pewdiepie before when he didn't have a toad *Nooo*
and all this
weird
shit
to hide the fact he's not
really that entertaining
it hurts-
it hurts
when you say these things
so I asked you bros to say something nice, okay?
so I asked you bros to say something nice!
take all our differences aside, alright?
and let us all just come together
and be nice
So I asked you bros on Facebook... uhm...
so i asked you bros on facebook to say something
to say something nice
I-I thought I would just read through it
through it and see what you guys say
Scheiffer Bates
SCHEIFFER BATES!
"I would like to climb inside your vagina."
Now you listen here, you son of a bitch! alright?
I WILL FIND YOU
AND I WILL FUCK YOU! ALRIGHT?
I will climb inside YOUR vagina
"Despite what people might say... I feel like your content has become a lot more
mature and genuine lately"
THANK YOU!!
as you can tell.
It's a lot more mature and GENUINE!!
"You're one of the very few people on YouTube
that achieve that level on honesty, and I really appreciate it!"
"Just kidding, I-
There always has to be a twist, huh?
is that how we're gonna do it?
There's gonna be a twist on everything?
Ok, well...
...uuuh...
Felix, I don't want you to die. I'm baking you a pie. Oh boy that was cringey I'll just go embarrass jacksepticeye
Felix, I don't want you to die. I'm baking you a pie. Oh boy that was cringy *I AGREE* Ill just go embarrass jacksepticeye
The fuck are you sayin?
"Pewds, you make my life and everything better.
Whenever I am in a dark place, or when I feel I need a friend,
I usually go to watch your videos and know that even if the world is against me,
I know that you will always be there
That is so sweet, okay?
that is ACTUALLY sweet
thank you, Bulma!
"Keep staying AMAZING. And keep being your weird self. And know I just want your happiness Keep living up to your name."
*sigh*
Was that so hard, goddamit?
thank you, Bulma! That's a very nice comment.
I'm really glad people appreciate the fact that
*laughs*
Cause a lot of people are like:
of people that are like you know what you
"You know what? You don't have to upload daily okay!?"
"I can tell you are running out of ideas, Poods.
tell you're running out of ideas poods
FUCK YOU
..eh..what is this video?
You're not playing a game? Why do you
you're not playing a game? why do you
even bother uploading?"
I am trying really hard to upload everyday
because I know a lot of people want me to do that
and i'm glad people appreciate it
so that really means alot.
THANK YOU!
see here again,
"I watch your video's everyday and I sure will miss you if you ever stop making them. Take care buddy"
You know anytime I go:
"WHY AM STILL HERE?
JUST TO SUFFER?"
I know at least some people find
joy in my suffering
"I enjoy "New Pewds", you have a unique way of doing videos. It refreshing watching something different you make me smile everyday, so thank you for that."
*laughs*
I'm not used to these compliments I'm like:
"what the fuck is this?"
*reads GLOCO's message*
oh no
How is this a good thing?
*continues reading*
I wouldn't encourage dropping out of
college to pursue YouTube but,
this guy did it and... eh... It worked out for him so,
you know
*claps* Bravo and it makes me feel really
proud that I inspired someone
I think that's very cool
I feel -I feel more
responsible for another person's life
than I ever -ever wanted but that's
amazing honestly, that's so cool
So, best of luck to you GLOCO
Man, this is heavier than I thought *laughs*
I started this video on such a joking -wh- they were- like Slippy
didn't even want to be here anymore
*Reads Taylor's comment*
Ok I think we're being a little- little over dramatic here but I
appreciate the poetry sort-of-ish
*reading*
This is great for my ego by the way it's not like it
was bad enough before you know and I'm
reading all this I'm like well you know
what I guess I am the greatest youtuber
of all time yeah you know what I guess I
make the best content on YouTube
*reading*
that's cool I guess I guess that's the
thing like when you've done videos for
seven years I guess they're bound to be
different you know it's just the it's
just how it is but for anyone and if not
then I think I want to grow I want to
get better and make better content no
but for real I appreciate and I'm glad
I'm growing with my audience in a way
it's it's only natural for some people
to not like and change but I'm really
glad that a lot of a lot of people and
it seems like the majority appreciate it
and I'm able to do stuff that I'm really
happy with instead of just catering to a
few people that really want me to be a
certain way I'm really glad that you
guys allow me to do the kind of videos
that I enjoy and it really means a lot I
don't know keep talking but it's amazing
I know a lot of youtubers struggled with
that and I feel very honored and
privileged to be able to do this
*reading*
I see-I see I think every
youtuber probably sees this kind of
comments where people talk about
depression and how their videos help
in the way we shoul- to me-and I think a
lot of youtubers we just see it and
we're like such a responsibility and
it's such a to feel like that is that
these people watch you that really need
it and it also almost seems a bit like
it's an exaggeration that how the fuck
with my videos help with depression like
it's not going to do shit I don't know
whenever I kind of do the same thing
like whenever I feel down I like to just
distract myself I guess it really helps
when you're feeling down
to distract yourself I think that's a
good tip and keep busy and don't don't
let your brain take over
*reading*
thank you thank you guys for watching
it's always weird when fans thank me I'm
like well I didn't you guys make it pop-
pop-possible and I wouldn't be here
without you so really I'm the one who's
saying thanks let's have a look on
Twitter and see if people are equally
nice you are one of the best youtubers
ever creep-keep up the great work no I'm
not absolutely nice but thank you I
thank you so much for all the nice
compliments I didn't think I wou-it would really
mean so much especially with how it
started up you know it really means a
lot thank you and like I was saying I
wouldn't be here if it wasn't for you
guys and the fact that you guys get an
enjoyable and kick out of what I do it's
amazing and I'll never forget it and
I'll never stop saying thank you for it
so stay awesome and I'll see you bros in
the next video and that's
PEW-DIE-PIE
*weeeeeeeeeeeeeee-
-eeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeee*
I'll Thank You PJ that's that fucking
picture I said say something nice PJ
fuck you PJ you're the fucking worst.
Why do you stil l have that picture by the way
way freaking me out
It's freaking me out
Hey Vsauce, Michael here